what's up so I'm here sitting inside the
crowded ei play and I just happened to
find a mr. Vince Zampella here in the
audience Maurice pine what's going on
Vince how you feeling today I'm feeling
great I love this stuff
I love seeing new games I mean someone's
super excited about that men on PC right
yeah so you guys may have seen that
Vince was tweeting yesterday and there
has been a bunch of speculation so you
want to just get right to it
sure I mean we're not ready to show all
of our stuff yet we're working on a
bunch of stuff it's amazing the teams
are kicking ass but we wanted to bring a
little tidbit so we've been working with
Lucas on getting the name and kind of
the setting for what our Star Wars games
gonna be em we're gonna talk about it
right now oh you guys got any guesses I
bet you the the Internet is going wild
right now I hope so
so the Star Wars name is Jedi fallen
order whoo so Star Wars Jedi fallen
order yeah so it kind of gives you some
idea that you'll be playing a guy so
does that mean I get to like hold a
lightsaber yes
so Vince you got a gun anything else
well it takes place during the dark
times
trying to be a little vague here but
when the Jedi's are being hunted so it's
gonna be expect Acula so for other like
the hardcore nerds out there who want to
know like where in the timeline like
what between which episodes is it
between three and four okay
all right between three four but sounds
like a nice time you got it eh any other
tidbits it's not a nice it's a dark time
it's a dark time bad time does that mean
this could just be all dark and it's
serious it's amazing all right so I
think people are now anxiously want to
know like what wedding can we play the
game it will be holiday of next year
2019 not this year so sorry it's a
destiny hope yeah but now that we know
we can set expectations we're all gonna
be you amped up and hopefully we'll hear
from more from you maybe and maybe next
year
oh yeah well Vince it was great to see
you thanks for stopping by the show
today we do have a little bit more news
on Star Wars so I'm gonna toss it over
to Dennis